- Hier soir, la planète
entière a retenu son souffle
lorsqu'une une bombe russe
est tombée dans le périmètre
ukranienne de Zaporijjia
et a provoquée un incendie.
Puis, la pression est retombée.
Cette centrale,
la plus importante,
comprend six réacteurs
nucléaires construits par
et 1995 et elle fournit près du
quart de l'électricité du pacit.
Concrètement, la frappe
n'a endommagé qu'un bâtiment
administratif, mais vu les
dimensions de la centrale, on a
MICHEL FORTMANN, chercheur,
'analyse stratégique
- C'est vraiment Tchernobyl
multiplié par cinq ou six,
une attaque ciblée surcette cec,
mais là, je pense qu'on est dans
la science-fiction et, fortio
catastrophe... et je pense quec.
- Dans les faits, ce scénario
catastrophe est as
improbable, disent les experde ,
construit un peu partoutdans lee
en matière de sécurité.
Par exemple, le coeur, un véeure
tombeau d'acier, peut
supporter d'immenses pressions,
et la centrale elle-même,
de ciment, pourrait résister
à l'impact causé te
d'un avion de ligne.
RLEAU, ingénieur nucléaire
prof. retraité Polytechnique Mtl
- En plus de ça, c à jour pour
augmenter leur sécurité après
les événements de Fukushima.
Donc, c'est à peu près ce qu'il
(explosion)
- Même la compar
avec l'accident de Tchernobyl,
en 1986, dont le réacteur a
surchauffé en raison du manque
de liquide de refroidissement,
- Le fait qu'il y ait
trois sy
refroidissement, c'est
beaucoup plus important quebyl.
Donc, les probabilités sont
beaucoup, beaucoien sûr, il y a
toujours le facteur humain
qui peut changer la donne.
L'Agence internationale
de l'énergie atomi
a invité la Russie et l'Ukraine
à une négociation en vue
des sites nucléairesanger par l.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-C